as we continue in integrated rangeland
management down this road of honing our
skills as grazing managers now we're
going to talk about those specific
grazing methods or systems that can be
applied to to manage goals on land keep
in mind there's a lot of things that a
grazing system or a grazing management
plan can do can help the vegetation it
can improve the ecological quality of
the land these items are from the
National rangeland and pasture handbook
another thing that they say there is
that you can improve the efficiency of
grazing through uniform use of all
grazing units so that is one thing that
we do know if you graze smaller units
appropriately you can have uniform use
across
you
what Congrats not accomplished they
can't rectify mismanagement because of
some other larger overriding factors
such as the wrong species an incorrect
stocking rate or some major distribution
problems such as water not being
available except every three miles or in
this these graphs below you see this
really really steep country on the right
hand side and those black spots on the
landscape are our cows a grazing system
isn't going to help that animals use
those landscapes it's going to take
something else another we have really
long large long term woody encroachment
into plants that's got to be
accomplished by a season and a type of
animal a grazing method is not going to
accomplish changes in those systems
let's talk about these systems we'll
talk about the first which is the kind
of easiest grazing system that can be
done and that is what we call continuous
or season-long it's just one pasture
livestock are placed on that pasture in
the spring and they're removed at the
end of the season or in other words are
grazed all year are all season in one
pasture so there's some advantages to
this system one it's really simple the
the input the cost and input is pretty
low just have to permit or fence around
the outside there is also an advantage
because livestock production can be
really high on these continuous
season-long systems because animals have
all the choice they need they can choose
any plant any time across that landscape
of course there are quite a few
disadvantages too one is if you've got a
really really large pasture or large
allotment you may have difficulty
actually managing or finding the cattle
so that can be a problem plants that are
available that once that animals will
eat even though it's healthy for them to
have maximum choice they're always going
to eat their favorite plants so we tend
to see in season-long systems we often
see the most desirable plants
being a disadvantage because they're the
ones that are always eaten and the same
can be true of riparian quality if you
look at that stream going down the
middle of this pasture animals have
access to that all year round that can
be okay if it's not really heavy grazing
but I'm in hand in the summer every
summer animals are probably going to
camp out on that on the riparian
vegetation there so it can be pretty
hard on repairing systems also it's not
very well adapted season-long systems
are not really great on areas that have
a lot of topographic challenges so on
the other hand these systems can work
really well in fairly small moderate
sized pastures in the plains or in areas
where we have moisture in the summer
areas where there's not a huge riparian
concern and where most of the plants
growing are good forage plants and
there's not a lot of differentiated
inferential between the desired and
undesirable plants so the system can
work really well in some places and it's
a challenging in others to overcome some
of those challenges the next system up
in intensity would be a deferred
rotation system so here's a past here's
a set of three I'm sorry instead of four
pastors that are managed the three
pastors that are managed in this case
are the North pasture the upland pasture
and the South pasture what we see here
is that the three pastures are
management and one is deferred every
year in other words one is not grazed
until after seed set so I in the year
one we see that the upland pasture is
deferred and the North pasture starts
out being raised and then animals are
moved to the South pasture and then
they're finally moved to the upland
pasture later in the year and the next
year the deferred pastures the North
pasture so animals start in the South
pasture they're moved the upland pasture
and then later in the summer they moved
back to the North pasture the North
pasture did not have any grazing in that
period from initiation to seed set and
then only receive grazing at the end at
the end of the season so that's how you
see on this chart that we the first year
the upland pasture is deferred
to the north bastard heard in the last
or third year in this rotation the South
pasture was deferred that's why it's
called the deferred rotation because
it's the actual deferment that is being
rotated not the cows I mean the cows are
being rotated too but the important
point is that the deferment is being
rotated some important points of this
system one is that the animals are using
all of the units they're using all of
the available area so there's no
extensive stocking rate there's no high
stocking rate involved and and that's
that's good because you're taking stock
rate and you're taking a number of
animals and you're spreading across the
whole units the stocking rate is
actually fairly low and animal
performance is still fairly high because
animals still have quite a bit of use of
the area and they are able to choose
their pet their diets not quite as high
as that continuous system is still
pretty good riparian areas can benefit
from this because they're at least only
going to be grazed once every three
years during that really hot dry season
the other two years out of any three
they would they would be rested or
deferred they would not be grazed and
I'd also it's an advantage to wildlife
because there's always gonna be some
pastures that are not being used by
livestock and that flipside of that
there's always gonna be some pastures
that were just used by livestock and
often we find with large ungulates like
deer and elk and pronghorn that they
often those animals like following the
cattle or the Sheep because the
livestock will take down some of the
dead material and then that makes for
good resources so we often see wildlife
following the livestock and this system
allows for that next step FN is the rest
rotation system case we have three
pastures a lot of rest rotations are
based on three pastures the difference
between this and deferred rotation is
that now one of the pastures is rested
for a whole year you see in year one of
this diagram the spring pasture is
grazed early in the season then animals
are moved at hill pasture and during
that time
creak pastors not grazed at all that
whole year okay that's good because it
gives some pastors rest for a whole year
and it means that the plants that aren't
going to be grazed by livestock they
might be grazed by wildlife but they're
not going to be grazed by livestock for
that whole year it's bad because you're
taking all of your animals and you're
concentrating them in two-thirds of the
area at least in this case when you had
three pasture they'd be concentrated in
2/3 of the area so unless this is a
unless there's a decrease in stocking
rate with rest rotations we can see kind
of heavy use of areas that are grazed in
each year on the other hand that use is
is followed by a long period of rest the
downside to this pasture has to do with
animal performance we often see
relatively well lower animal performance
in rest rotation systems because animals
are always going on to a pasture that
was deferred or rested meaning there's
always a buildup of biomass of dead
biomass so they have to sort through
that dead biomass before they can get to
the green better forage so animal
performance can be quite low in rest
rotation systems the flipside to that
these systems weren't designed so much
with livestock and while in mind they
were designed with giving plants every
opportunity to reseed themselves so what
you see in these systems is that a
pasture will not be gracious and spring
to the plants go to seed then they will
be grazed as a way to Tromp the seed
into the soil and then that same pasture
will be rested for the following years
okay so for example look in this diagram
we have in year one the Hill posture is
not grazed from April to July then it is
grazed in August through September
during that time the grazing can shatter
the seeds and stomp them into the ground
the following year the hill pastures not
graze at all so those plants that were
stopped into the ground can now turn
into turn into plants now I don't know
that there's a lot of data that shows
that this actually does yield more new
plants but that certainly is the design
behind
system the one that here's an example of
one of the most intensive systems we
have that would be arrested I'm sorry a
short-duration or a high intensity low
frequency system it's where you have
multiple pastors and every pastor is
grazed by a lot of animals for a short
period and usually each individual
pastors grace several times per year so
let's just take a look at this a pattern
if you look at the diagram down there
it's grazed in January and then it's
grazed again in May and then it's grazed
again in July and then it's grazed again
in November so that pastors raised for
only a few days ten fifteen seven days
but it's grazed multiple times a year
this system was designed to mimic some
of the systems in Africa of large herds
of wildebeest and then other kinds of
prong of antelope coming through the
system and so you see these waves of
animals the advantage from the animal
standpoint is that at least several
times a year the animal has green forage
to go on regrowth so the system was
really designed with animals in mind but
it also has the advantage of leveling
the playing field of all the plants you
put a lot of animals into one pasture at
one time that restricts their choices
between plants but it does make sure
that all the plants are grazed so it
makes sure that the zero plants aren't
always getting hit that the undesirable
or less desirable plants are also
getting eaten so these intensive systems
often involve higher stocking rates and
they have a you know a large number of
animals on pastures for a short period
they can be quite effective in areas
where you have rain during the growing
season or at least throughout most of
the year I tend to not work as well out
here in the Intermountain West where we
have a pretty short period of moisture
so they so these systems are really
adapted to just a few areas where
there's moisture throughout the year and
can really handle that higher sustained
grazing another whole set of systems
could best be just defined as decision
decisional or management intensive
systems
these are systems that have just one
heard and many pastors multiple pastors
and the decisions about whether to move
the animals and where depends on the
amount of forage that's available the
amount of water what activities are
happening in the livestock units such as
calving or lambing they're often used to
facilitate other practices such as
hanging or stockpiling enough forage for
prescribed great for our fire and then
finally these systems are probably the
most common in the world and their
success can be really high or low
depending on the bill the ability of the
manager the decisions of the manager
some names that we would call these
decisional systems would include the
best pasture system this is where you
move livestock to pastures that look
best in terms of forage availability it
was designed in the arid Southwest is
used a lot in New Mexico Arizona those
areas because oftentimes a storm will
come through and it may put several
inches of rain on a on a pasture but it
might just be on one pasture or one area
of the ranch so in order to use that
green forage the manager makes a
decision to go to the best pasture
available complimentary systems such as
those that are up in the central plains
are where you have a pasture and a
cultivated area you've cultivated some
part of the ranch to have green forage
either early in the season or late in
the season so you're making a pasture to
complement the rest of the range so
that's a complementary or decisional
system when you have to elevation to
give you the advantage to be able to go
to green forage at higher elevation you
can accomplish a seasonal suitability
system seasonal suitability is the idea
that you're following the green you're
always in put animals on higher and
higher elevation because of the growth
pattern of different vegetation types
that's a seasonal suitability system in
Idaho that's following the green or
seasonal suitability is often seen where
we start out in the winter range down in
the salt desert shrub where the shrubs
in the winter a few grasses to give
that energy and shrubs to give the
protein and will stay down there during
the winter months then they start to
move in the bench limbs there's a whole
set of spring fall ranges that green up
in April May time and animals graze
those often times that's where we have
animals calving or lambing out it's a
very common system used in sheep
production so you have lambing occurring
that spring fall range from then on
animals just follow up the mountains up
into the summer range we're up in the
summer range it's high elevation there
can be snowpack up into June or July so
you can have green forage up until it
starts to cool down in August September
the case of sheep usually those owners
will ship the Lambs off of the mountain
in September take them to sale because
by that time they'll be fat ready to eat
ready to sell and then they'll just
slowly move the ewes down the mountain
into that spring fall range again and
then down onto the winter range this
system also works with cattle just that
the calves may have to be brought off
and brought to some higher quality
forage in that September October
November we'll often see the cat the
steers and heifers being taken off and
gone going to higher quality forage it's
a pretty simple system age-old system
works really well because the animals
are eyes on green forage and the
vegetation usually has time to recover
once the animals get off there's still
enough resources and time for those
plants to recover so it can be really
easy on the range and really easy on the
animal which method is best well it
really depends I've seen all of these
methods work and all of these methods
fail depending on the skill of the
manager and depending on what management
goals are whether it be for livestock
performance whether riparian areas are
concern whether livestock production is
the issue whether there's a concern over
wildfire or risk and what and how the
landscape would respond to that so all
of these systems can be good at one time
and may be poor at others so there's no
one system fits all it depends on the
skill of the manager nearly all systems
can work and nearly all systems can fail
there are thousands of variations on
theme all of these examples in this
PowerPoint are of one heard systems
multiple pastures or one pasture and one
herd there's a whole set of systems that
are designed with multiple herds so
there's a like there's just variations
on this theme depending on how many
pastures you have exactly what the rest
deferment grazing rotation combinations
are are quite endless but no matter the
system you've got to get a stocking
right the species of animal and you've
got to pay attention to distribution
patterns because this the grazing method
is just one of the parts of the equation
and all methods need to be flexible to
be managed and so if the manager is good
and they have the flexibility they can
manage for disturbances on the ground
such as fire weeds droughts animals used
by wildlife or by wild horses all of
those things are things that can change
a management plan and that requires
flexibility so that's about the main
aspects very simplified version of
grazing methods there's some other
readings in this class that will give
you some more of the details for each
method but keep your eye on the ball
it's a manage of it's just an aspect of
managing the time that pastures are
grazed or arrested and then we'll next
talk about distribution and some of the
other elements about making your grazing
method successful